everyone knows who won but not everyone
knows how we have not to ask the biggest
question in a generation in about we
need a leader understand whoever does
our bill to their hearts people are
feeling angry ignored is the immigration
it'll be honest is it race which
countries don't you like new people come
in we have squeezed them we want to
return to a time when we knew our place
when things made sense
fictional not how to change the course
of history
we have to hack the political system
package I'm talking about altering the
matrix of politics social media
platforms are designed to find
like-minded people our software will
locate and target people that know
campaign is ever targeted before people
who don't and have never voted three
million extra votes that the other side
have no idea exists this is an
insurgency against the establishment
really build something that will restock
the odds in our favor what are your
expectations realistically she creates
Biggest Loser glove sense it's the fall
of the Berlin Wall very large yes
let's take the fight for Britain begins
you are feeding a toxic culture of fear
and hate
you can't close the box once it's been
opened it's your edge when you found
there is a new politics in town one that
you can't control
[Music]
you